-I saw you in Brooklyn,
by the way, performing your --
your concert, and I was --
-"Madame X."
-Mm-hmm.
-It was unbelievable.
-Thank you.
-And I -- What I loved about it
was that you chose
these smaller arenas.
You always do stuff
that no one's doing.
You zig when people are zagging.
-Right.
-[ Laughter ]
-And then, people --
You can quote me on that.
And -- But here's what I was
going to ask you. Do you --
-Did I make any money?
-No.
No, I wasn't going to
ask you that.
-I didn't. [ Laughing ]
-I was going to ask you...
When people take your ideas --
you do all these things first.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then people take your ideas
and they don't give you credit,
and I go,
"No, Madonna did that already."
-Yeah, and they also
don't do it as good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean --
-That's -- [ Laughs ]
That's exactly right.
-That sounds really,
um, arrogant...
-Yeah.
-...but it's kind of true.
-No.
-Yeah.
-"Madame X."
This is on Paramount+ tomorrow.
What -- What do you hope
people take away from this,
from watching this documentary?
-Um, that art is important
in our lives.
I don't think people
emphasize that enough.
-Yeah.
-I -- I'm really inspired by
James Baldwin the writer.
-Yeah.
-Have you heard of him?
-Of course.
-Don't lie.
-I have heard of James Baldwin.
-Okay, yeah.
He's -- was a great source of
inspiration for me growing up,
and he was a great source
of inspiration for the show.
And one of the things I quote
over and over again in the show
is that artists are here
to disturb the peace.
And so --
-Wow.
-And so I hope
that I have disturbed
not only your peace
this afternoon but...
-You always disturb my peace.
-...people's peace
while they watch the show,
but I mean that in the best way.
-Oh, yeah.
You get in good trouble.
-Good trouble.
-Yeah, you really do.
No, no, no!
Now, why would you --
Madonna. Madonna!
[ Sultry R&B music plays ]
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
Stop it.
Oh, my heavens.
Stop it. Stop it.
I don't know what to do.
Stop it right now.
Absolutely -- This is --
♪♪
-No one's gonna see anything.
My God.
-Sorry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
Every -- Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what --
I don't what to --
-Because life is not just
about interviewing kiddies.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
-Is that right?
-Don't you want
to talk to an adult?
-Is that right? Yeah.
-Let's have some
adult conversation.
-Are you talking to an adult
right now?
-I'm not sure.
[ Laughter ]
I'm talking to someone who's --
I feel, like, you're --
You're in some kind of conflict
right now.
-Oh, interesting.
-Yeah, have you been
to a therapist?
-I went a -- I went
once or twice. I didn't --
It wasn't my thing.
-No.
-Do you go to therapy?
-Um, I just -- I write.
[ Laughter ]
I write.
-So -- So, no?
-It's a form of therapy.
No, I write, and I also hope
that I have good friends
and I talk my [bleep] out
with people and, you know,
that's a kind of therapy,
don't you think?
-I can be your friend.
-You think?
-Yeah. You should call me.
-You should've -- You know,
you came over to my house once.
-I did. I had a great time.
You introduced me to "Ladybug."
Um, whatever it's called.
"Miraculous."
I didn't know what that was.
-Do your kids watch it?
-Now, because of you.
-Okay.
-I do everything because of you.
Oh, my gosh. Is this like --
See? This is why
I don't go to therapy.
It gets -- It gets --
It gets nowhere.
-You get --
Yep, and it's gonna --
Just talk to me.
-Do you smoke?
-No.
-Me neither.
-I don't.
I smoke for photo shoots.
-But you never smoked?
-No.
-Because of your voice?
-Yeah, I just don't like it.
-Yeah, me neither. Do you vape?
-I'd rather...
I like...opiates.
[ Laughter ]
-Ridiculous.
I want to show a clip.
Here is Madonna in "Madame X."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-♪ It's not gypsy blood ♪
♪ We live between
life and death ♪
♪♪
♪ Waiting to move on ♪
♪ And in the end ♪
♪ We accept it ♪
♪♪
♪ We shake hands with our fate ♪
♪ And we walk past ♪
♪ There's no rest for us
in this world ♪
♪♪
♪ Finally a lost love ♪
-Yes! That's what
I'm talking about!
More with Madonna
after the break!
"Madame X," everybody!
Come on back!